je vous montre un instrument pour des
opérations se parler ici effectivement
le chirurgien et en plus de chirurgie
thoracique en fait je vais avoir deux
commandes ici qui me permettent de
commander directement des petites mains
robotiques qu'on peut retrouver dans une
machine qui est planqué de l'autre côté
alors ici les lunettes qui me permettent
de voir en 3D pour avoir la profondeur
et regarder je peux manipuler et je peux
venir reposer des objets très facilement
et en fait j'ai piloter ces deux mains
directement on a plus se parler ici de
chirurgie digestive mais une fois de
plus et une innovation qui est super
intéressante je vais avoir des
télécommandes ici tu vas voir des
commandes directement de joystick qui me
permet de venir repositionner ma main
pour pouvoir commander directement mes
robots l'idée ici c'est de voir comment
est-ce que la robotique peut venir
améliorer et technologies médicales on
peut bien évidemment le voir dans plein
d'industries différentes ça me bluff
c'est très cool alors j'ai une tête très
bizarre avec ses lunettes mais une fois
de plus je trouve que le système est
complètement dingue est très très facile
à prendre en main pour ça extrêmement
bluffant dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires parce que
ce système c'est probablement l'avenir
d'abord ce système pour avoir de la
télémédecine ou de la télé opération à
distance je trouve ça juste génial le
nom du robot s'appelle versus et puis la
boîte vient de Cambridge elle s'appelle
CMA c'est NR parce que vous en pensez
bien évidemment dans les commentaires